[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schönen guten abend und
willkommen alles wichtige vom sport von
norbert könig abend beim g 20 uhr beim
klimagipfel wird versucht sich auf mehr
klimaschutz zu einigen unsere großen
themen heute
gemischte bilanz beim g20-gipfel die
führenden wirtschaftsmächte bleiben vage
beim thema klimaneutralität
kampf gegen die erderwärmung die
weltklimakonferenz in glasgow beginnt
mit eindringlichen appellen und
triumph in wien tennisprofi alexander
schweres gewinn seien 18 titel
ich verlasse rom mit unerfüllten
hoffnungen aber zumindest sind sie nicht
begraben so das fazit des
un-generalsekretärs
görisch zum ende des g20 gipfels heute
für insgesamt 80 prozent der weltweiten
treibhausgasemissionen sind die 20
wirtschaftsstärksten länder
verantwortlich über die ergebnisse ihres
treffens mrt wissen
sie müssten viel mehr geld in die hand
nehmen als ein paar münzen ihr kleines
opfer an ozeans den meeresgott soll so
die legende zwar ein wiedersehen den
raum verheißen doch um die welt und die
menschen zu retten vor dem klimawandel
reicht der pr termin am trevi-brunnen
nicht für ihr unterfangen bekamen die
g-20 heute deshalb königlichen rat vom
britischen thronfolger
wir müssen jetzt eben worte in noch
bessere daten verwandeln bei die zukunft
der menschheit und der natur auf dem
spiel steht ist es zeit unsere
differenzen beiseite zu schieben aber
die g20 die 80 prozent der
klimafeindlichen emissionen verursachen
bleiben das zieldatum für das erreichen
der klimaneutralität um die mitte des
jahrhunderts man will sich anstrengen
den temperaturanstieg auf 1,5 statt zwei
grad zu begrenzen wie genau bleibt offen
den nicht fortschritt gegenüber dem
pariser abkommen werden sie dennoch als
erfolg noch einmal zu verdeutlichen und
sagen 15 grad muss in reichweite sein
das ist ein sehr sehr gutes ergebnis dem
sich alle auch angeschlossen wenn
gewissermaßen die mitte dieses
jahrhunderts gemeinsam in den blick
genommen wird dann ist das schon mal ein
fortschritt auf denen man vor ein paar
jahren nicht rechnen durfte und insofern
sollte man das auch nicht unterschätzen
aber auch die aufgabe nicht
unterschätzen die damit verbunden ist
jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass die ziele
nicht nur ziele bleiben immerhin mit
einem kleinen schutz klimapolitik
beenden die usa und die eu jetzt ihren
handelsstreit europa darf ohne
strafzölle wieder begrenzte mengen stahl
liefern wenn er mit weniger co2 ausstoß
produziert wurde man kann sich das
ergebnis hier schön reden mit ein paar
fortschritten die es wirklich gibt aber
die mehrheit der g20 sieht im
klimaschutz ein risiko nicht eine chance
für ihre wirtschaft ein aufbruchsignal
für glasgow fehlanzeige für die
demonstranten in rom haben die g20
einmal mehr versagt
die g 20 staats und regierungschefinnen
und schiffsreisen also von rom gleich
weiter in schottische glasgow auch bei
der dortigen weltklimakonferenz die
heute eröffnet wurde geht es darum die
erderwärmung auf möglichst 15 grad zu
begrenzen
zwei wochen lang beraten vertreter und
vertreter von fast 200 ländern über die
weitere umsetzung des pariser
klimaabkommens alle fünf jahre sollen
sich demnach die staaten erklären wie
sie den austausch von treibhausgasen
weiter verringert wollen nach un angaben
reichen die bisherigen pläne aber bei
weitem nicht aus aus glasgow diana zu
machen
auch in schottland streiten
demonstranten für die rettung der welt
sie erwarten von der un klimakonferenz
die heute in glasgow beginnt einen
konkreten handlungsplan
25.000 delegierte wollen erreichen dass
die erde sich im vergleich zum
neunzehnten jahrhundert um maximal 1,5
grad erwärmt 1,1 grad sind es schon
jetzt drängt daher die worte der un
klimachefin zur eröffnung der konferenz
humanit die menschheit hat klare
entscheidungen zu treffen entweder wir
schaffen es jetzt schnell einen großen
teil des co2 ausstoßes zu reduzieren
oder wir akzeptieren dass der menschheit
auf diesem planeten eine düstere zukunft
bevorsteht und jetzt planen die welt
weiß das und doch wird immer noch mehr
co2 ausgestoßen china die usa und europa
sind die hauptverantwortlichen in
glasgow aber kommen wirklich alle
zusammen fast 200 staaten darunter auch
die ärmsten häufig am schwersten
betroffen von dürren überschwemmungen
artensterben ihnen wurden bei der
pariser klimakonferenz 100 milliarden
dollar jährlich versprochen um maßnahmen
zu ergreifen doch bisher nur 80 prozent
gezahlt
solange wir die historische
verantwortung der länder des nordens
ignorieren in diesen verhandlungen
werden wir natürlich kein erfolgreiches
ergebnis erzielen können
es geht in glasgow um klimagerechtigkeit
zwischen nord und süd aber auch zwischen
alt und jung und so wie die meisten es
hier sehen um nicht weniger als das
überleben auf unserer einen welt
auch für uns vor ort unserer umwelt
experte volker angriffs volker die
staaten haben ihre pläne eingereicht wie
sie ihren treibhausgas ausstoß
verringern wollen reicht das
nein es reicht nicht also diese pläne
wenn sie denn überhaupt umgesetzt werden
würden bedeuten dass wir bei mindestens
2,7 grad erderwärmung bis zum ende
dieses jahrhunderts landen würden und da
kann man sofort sehen es muss noch ganz
ganz viel mehr geschehen und da wollen
wir schauen ob das bis zum ende der
konferenz dann auch so sein wird und was
sind die weiteren große streitthemen
dieser welt klimakonferenz
eines der ganz großen themen ist der
artikel 5 nach dem pariser abkommen da
geht es um die internationale
zusammenarbeit und da wird darüber
gestritten wenn die jetzt zb ein land in
einem anderen land ein windpark bauen
würde wo wird die co2 ersparnis an
gerechnet da wo der neue windpark steht
oder in dem land das es bezahlt hat
darüber wird seit 2005 zehn jahre schon
gestritten dann geht es tatsächlich
darum für die entwicklungsländer viel
viel mehr zu tun der globale süden wer
betroffen ist von den klimaveränderungen
von der klimakatastrophe
wer braucht ganz viel geld um
anpassungsmaßnahmen gegen den
klimawandel zu finanzieren
schon 2020 waren 100 milliarden dollar
pro jahr jedes jahr bis 20.25
versprochen es ist noch nicht eingezahlt
20 milliarden müssen hier in glasgow und
mindestens noch zusammenkommen wenn das
geschieht dann könnte man sagen okay da
ist ein bisschen was vorangekommen so
wie es im pariser abkommen beschlossen
wurde also auch ein geld fehlt es noch
fehler für die einschätzung voll krass
sie wollen noch mehr erfahren über den
klimagipfel in glasgow dann gehen sie
auf unsere zdf heute app dort haben wir
in unserem klima da die wichtigsten
zahlen zur klimakrise grafisch für sie
aufbereitet
kommen wir zur corona pandemie da
fordert der bundesgesundheitsminister
ein bund länder gipfel zum thema
auffrischungsimpfungen aktuell reiche
das booster tempo in deutschlands praxen
nicht so sparen gegenüber der bild am
sonntag bayerns ministerpräsident müller
forderte ebenfalls auffrischungsimpfung
für alle altersgruppen kritik daran gibt
es jedoch von ärztevertretern der grund
dieser diskussion sind weiterhin
steigende corona zahlen so meldet das
robert-koch-institut
1887 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind
3155 mehr als vor einer woche außerdem
starben 33 menschen im zusammenhang mit
19 innerhalb eines tages die sieben tage
incidents ist weiter hoch gegangen auf
jetzt
149,4
31 oktober reformationstag
protestanten in aller welt erinnern
heute an die anfänge der evangelischen
kirche so auch in der wittenberger
schlosskirche der augustinermönch martin
luther soll hier vor rund 500 jahren
seine kritik am ablasshandel
veröffentlicht haben am ende stand die
gründe und der evangelischen kirche
und wir kommen zum sport felix ahlers
wäre fast schon zwei monate verschloss
das erfolgreichste jahr seiner karriere
den fünf titel in einem jahr hat er noch
nie gewonnen also das ist ein debüt zwei
wochen vor der inoffiziellen
weltmeisterschaft ist und bleibt der
olympiasieger in topform in zwei sätzen
gewinnt alexander zverev das atp turnier
in wien gegen den us amerikaner francis
tia
46 19 asse und die mehr als 80 prozent
erfolgreich platzierten ersten
aufschläge machen den unterschied gegen
den amerikaner francis kioyo der zum
dritten mal in einem großen finale steht
nur einmal hat es wäre jetzt klar das
nachsehen als wie ein trafo im zweiten
satz erfolgreich über das feld jagt
doch abseits aller showeinlagen ist der
olympiasieger aus hamburg der bessere
spieler mit 7 zu 5 und 6 zu 4 kommt der
24 jährige zu seinem 18 turniersieg
wieder frühere wimbledon-sieger michael
stich in seiner ganzen karriere nur
boris becker mit 49 turnier erfolgen im
einzel hat als deutscher tennisspieler
mehr geholt
und der fc augsburg hat nach fünf
pflichtspielen ohne sieg mal wieder
gewonnen trotz des 4 2 1 gegen vfb
stuttgart bleibt der fc aber
drittletzter einen punkt hinter dem vfb
die stuttgarter auf platz 13
kunstradsport ist eine deutsche domäne
bei der wm in stuttgart holt auch das
deutsche frauen-duo marquardt
vordermayer beim debüt gold alle titel
bleiben im lande
es ist eine mischung aus athletik
kondition akrobatik und konzentration
die deutschen wm debütantinnen selina
marquardt und hellen vordermayer zeugen
auf ihren rädern die sie liebevoll tiger
und panda nennen in den fünf minuten
ihrer kür von allem das beste und
gewinnen den titel auf dem einer
kunstrad bleibt lukas kohl eine klasse
für sich zum fünften mal nacheinander
wird der 25 jährige weltmeister mit
einer perfekten darbietung und macht
seinem spitznamen lukin ator alle ehre
gold im radball haben bernd und gerhard
mlady gewonnen keine brüder sondern
cousin interessant dann genau wer für
noch einen blick auf die
wetteraussichten morgen in der osthälfte
regen im südosten auch länger anhaltend
und kräftig sonst bei einem mix aus
sonne und wolken meist trocken an der
nordsee stürmisch 9 bis 15 grad und das
war es von uns um 21 uhr 45 begrüßte
hier bettina schausten zum heute journal
und jetzt geht es nahtlos weiter mit
berlin direkt mit theo koll